les chroniqueurs ont préparé des petites
expériences scientifiques que l'on peut
faire à la maison donc vous allez
également les voir chez vous alors pas
besoin de produits chimiques de lunettes
de protection
voilà on va pas mettre le feu au plateau
vous inquiétez pas mais vous pouvez les
faire également chez ou alors avant que
les chroniqueurs ne fassent l'expérience
qu'on posera une question et on
découvrira la réponse lors de son test
scientifique d'accord doit tenir en
vidéo s'il se foire complètement ce que
je skie ceci alors comme on a la chance
de vous avoir en plus igor et grichka
vous êtes vraiment ce que je vous dit
igor et grichka ces dépotoirs inaba se
mentir et ils sont allés sont très
respectés dans le monde de la science et
dans le monde de lakhdar cas voilà donc
juin ils vont pouvoir nous expliquer des
phénomènes scientifiques
voilà que vous allez voir alors
attention regardez cette image vous
allez jouer également chez pour garder
cette image
regardez cette image cette image vous
voyez dans cette image voilà très bien
pour faire rentrer un oeuf dur dans une
bouteille
on peut utiliser jean-michel un glaçon
un morceau de coton enflammé de la
vaseline tiède 1 où je dis pas la
quatrième un morse
ab je veux dire voilà quatrièmes noces
tu avais un morceau de papier enflammé
un morceau de coton flamenco toro la
guerre vous connaissez la réponse est
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai alors janvier
ce que vous pouvez nous faire la
démonstration si j'ai un oeuf et ma
personne à sarry bien sûr un oeuf amené
à mener les experts voilà alors jean mi
attention valter alors donc pour faire
rentrer un oeuf dur dans une bouteille
voilà il faut il faut un oeuf évidemment
qu'on a on a retiré la coquille
évidemment trop ça n'a aucun sens
d'accord il faut prendre un papier un
papier web papier pas coton un papier
c'est mieux une allumette pour
l'enflammer n'était pas cela il rendra
je vais essayer d'y rentrer oui voilà à
prendre on a lu le papier
ouais on met le papier mais dis moi il
est allé la fosse de l'oeuvre comme ça
d'accord ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
je savais c'est le bruit rayonné
l'oxygène sa forme des prêts sont le
fait alors pourquoi ça pourquoi ça mais
tout simplement il vient de le dire
la combustion va donc absorber lorsqu'il
l'oxygène créer une dépression est
aspiré le sanac la reprise et des
pressions pour vous mettre en oeuvre
bravo jean michel
avec vos parents du garçon qui voit là
mais ça marche mais attention benjamins
à on passe à votre expérience que ce
pacte que se passe-t-il si on met le feu
au papier d'un sachet de thé vide il va
directement se loger dans le pantalon
fabien lecoeuvre
il ne brûle pas il va s'envoler où il va
tripler de volume assez facile il va
s'envoler la s'envoler et oui alors il
va nous montrer c'est très simple alors
quelle est l'expérience de benjamin
fasse attention on a tous les salades or
ces références et pas pour des coupables
ils achètent comment où je peux voir ça
pour monter alors c'est quoi l'idée a
été promue comme ça c'est un petit
sachet tu es d'accord ok on découpe
comme ça
ouais et après on met horizontal et vous
allez voir que la condition d'assumer la
combustion va faire que le papier va
s'envoler ses s'y attendait et ben voilà
il me semble alors être faite le il
n'est pas brûlé complètement peut-être
que l'odeur normalement il est que alors
benjamin c'est votre deuxième chance
vous n'aurez que d'auchan c'est pas
correct les femmes j'ai eu trois chances
déjà way attention pas y voilà stan as
vous avez répété oui bien sûr à savoir
une heure les jeux tenir à tous sont
bannis ils brûlent tout simplement pas
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi ça mais ça c'est le principe de
la montgolfière est en fait c'est l'air
chaud qui fait qu'ils étaient plus léger
que l'air ambiant
ah ouais donc permet au oui mais la
première fois ci ça s'est pas envolé
pour nos besoins très précis c'est qu'il
n'y avait pas le tome i qui pouvait
faire effectivement apple aapl à tension
superficielle de l'air et c'est à cause
de ça qui reste est effondrée c'est
l'amérique ans ne s'est pas emballé à
l'américaine que se passe-t-il à
regarder cette image d'abord regarder
cette image photo qui vous plaît merci
regarder cette image que se passe-t-il
si on place un coton imbibé de liquide
vaisselle dans du lait et du colorant
alimentaire les couleurs vont se
disperser
des bulles multicolores vont apparaître
le lait se transforme au rhum et doc
gynéco apparaît comme ou non liquides va
se durcir
alors c'est la baisse a fait un
arc-en-ciel non couleur vont se
disperser
donc c'est là vous avez répété en fait
d'accord et ben écoutez on va voir alors
alors regarde donc là il ya des couleurs
alors ici on a de l'huile médium dans le
vert on met de l'huile dans le vert très
bien vers les îles met-il en plus belle
sa coupe ah bah alors c'est bon on
arrive dans le verbe anglais redon dédia
quoi dans le vert alors il ya du lait
ben ya de l'huile
ouais et ensuite on prend du colorant
ouais on en met d'accord
maintenant on en prend bien en couleur
et voilà alors à aa
et ensuite attention considérez-vous ah
bon pourquoi ces sales histoires dont je
vois c'est dangereux puisque la zone un
éclat de joie médicaux et alors que vous
passez personne n'a compris le président
s'attend maintenant à patienter à
s'impatienter
combien de minutes puisque c'est de la
merde ne riez pas mais non alors
franchement le sol arc en ciel que je
vois c'est dans la rue
alors comment ça se disent pas il
fallait qu'il fallait un pari que vous
fassiez que vous étiez alors on va le
regarder en vidéo est ce que vous avez
complètement farfelu matière d art d
aspirine j'appelle vraiment aux vrais
mots que se passe-t-il sur mélange de
l'amidon et de l'eau etc on le secoue
dans ses mains alors ce harem un fume
pendant plusieurs secondes le mélange de
bien solide
le liquide va sentir aussi mauvais qu'un
pays de castes a changé de couleur se
passe-t-il sur mélange de l'amidon et de
l'eau a mené la ramener le m et l'ange
devient solide alors le mélange de
virages alors ça alors
alors c'est très simple alors ici ou
ailleurs je ne vais pas faire des crêpes
lagarde
alors elle allait à l'origan matin alors
allez si vous avez des gants alors là
alors ça donc ça c'est quoi ça mais ça
c'est une craie ça c'est quoi ça bon je
suis pas une fiole un colorant en
collants filés main jaune c'est moche ça
c'est de l'eau ça c'est de l'eau ça
c'est de l'amidon voilà d'accord vous
faire des crêpes à la faune m combien de
l'eau toute la bouteille bas mais tous
métaux tata vient en effet d un mois je
serai peut-être est répartie frais dans
le commerce au lit alors rien mais là
j'avais déconner ça va être long vous
avez pas d'un truc à faire allez allez
vas-y vas-y alors vas-y et donc quoi tu
veux te vois tu dois mettre du colorant
aux forçats facile si on veut faire une
boule bleue comme ça ça fait juste mais
moi je vais vous la fin je voulais faire
en blanc moi je fais plus maître de
colorants cibox d'anor c'est normal ça
ramait attendait parce que c'est son
droit c'est pas ça c'est que ça c'était
bien comme ça alors a sonné il a dit
maltais lecteurs regardez mais non je
suis juste allé c'est non
j'aurais payé
et enfin isabelle adultes nous qui a eu
la meilleure expérience pour l'instant
pas moi c'est jean michel et jean michel
hallé isabelle question alors moi je dis
tout ce qui est pas répéter avec ma moto
taxi adacore va très bien alors fonds
disperser rapidement du poivre dans de
l'eau avec son doigt
il faut auparavant mettre ce dernier
dans sa bouche et son nez son oreille
on ne peut pas décrire mans pour tous à
laval alors isabelle vous le faites
souvent c'est dans l'oreille je voulais
aller en disant logement vous abusez 12e
et mettez alors faites comme d'habitude
rien à ce que vous faites donc je vous
le dis pour disperser rapidement du
poivre dans de l'eau avec son doigt il
faut auparavant remettre ce dernier dans
son oreille donc regarder je vais de
l'ue doivent par exemple si je me suis
trompé
ces salons quand même être là c'est
dommage aussi alors là ça marche aussi
dans le vert tu vois tu vois je voulais
mettre du poids en 2008 mais la sq
normalement ça doit être vraiment marre
de parler mais ton doigt dans l'oreille
ali longtemps
ban ki moon et calais ça aussi
j'aimerais bien me l a mis le feu
les panthéreaux pas dit ça marchera pas
m'a dit c'est grotesque
alors pourquoi ça marche pas mais parce
qu'en réalité c'est la saponification
qui crée l'élargissement 10 couleurs on
voudra on abuse de sa d'ailleurs avec
les couleurs doit se peuvent fonctionner
avec le poids requis sont des molécules
légère mais il faut du savon regarder
faudrait qu'il ait seulement voilà une
assiette
[Musique]
voilà
oui